we reviewed one of your old videos where
you talked about like pounding the
carton of egg whites yeah
um dude so funny yeah just looking at
you then yeah and now yeah how old are
you now 30. okay did you start in
Pharmacology or like no it was just
something that always interested me and
I just was always very very intrigued by
performance announcement optimization
um anything to do with maximizing
whatever you can in your life
essentially whether it's like cognitive
health or you know gym performance
whatever so yeah just kind of a nerd
damn what did you go to school for
marketing huh totally irrelevant yeah
and useless degree by the way yeah yeah
so then so then like how like when did
you start doing this full-time like when
did why did you start making YouTube
videos when did it like really start
working for you
um yeah so I've always been interested
so I sort of have like a baseline of
knowledge going into the video so that
you know helped me kind of get I don't
know the ball rolling immediately
because it's not like I started from
zero and then when tried to read a bunch
of studies and [ __ ] to yeah to then make
the videos it was more like I had some
time on my hands wrote some blog
articles somebody suggested I should
also make videos to go along with the
blog articles it's like okay so it was
just kind of what I knew at the time and
then since then it's evolved like fairly
significantly depending on what my
interests are I don't want to cut you
off I I just for the context of like you
starting like when you wrote those blogs
was there anyone that was like sort of
like inspired you to do it or was it
just more like a one-to-one like I'm
already writing this [ __ ] I'm I think
I'd be comfortable saying it to camera
yeah it was uh there were some people
who sort of like paved the way in the
like men's self-improvement space and
there were some guys on YouTube like
Alpha M who've been there forever and so
they're sort of a blueprint a little bit
and most of guys I knew though were
writers and they would write on their
blogs and I don't know write about how
to dress better how to get in shape yeah
just anything to do with maximizing
self-improvement essentially in men and
that's kind of where the Inception of
the name came because I saw all these
Brands making these you know catchy
little gimmicky rhymy names and stuff I
was like yeah what should I name my my
what's a good URL that's not taken yet
so I was just going through and picking
stuff that was like lifting related but
also sort of Lifestyle related or
whatever I could find yeah and one of
the only domains on my list that sounded
like decent to me memorable rhymed it
was that more place more days yeah so
even though it's kind of interesting
because I I don't know like I sometimes
I feel a bit misaligned with it as I get
older because I actually do you know am
involved with certain people that I feel
are very credible in the scientific
Community or legitimate doctors or
neuroscientists or whatever then here I
am like this douchey [ __ ] and more
plays more dates yeah yeah yeah dude
well they're tiny meat gang we're right
there with you dude yeah yeah we are
still your pain yeah so there's like
sometimes I feel there may be a barrier
to entry a little bit but it's like oh
I'm dealing with this guy a pickup
artist yeah yeah so but it's hard
because since then you've built your
entire brand on this name so it's like
it's hard to go back from that yeah but
it really does roll off the tongue more
plates more dates yeah so yeah if I go
to something else then I don't know I
don't even know what that would look
like trying to get back the the steam I
don't think you can yeah I think all you
can do is what we've done you know oh
yeah you want to come on the uh npmd
podcast yeah yeah yeah the MD kind of
yeah you can kind of trick people with
that that's what people have suggested
but I don't want to be that misleading
no no of course not no yeah no I just
mean in conversation yeah I know what
you mean yeah yeah I've considered that
though but then it sucks because then
you know that like all the handles on on
the social media platforms who's gonna
take the the more plates more dates and
what are they going to do with it yeah I
don't know it's just a lot to think
about and then I don't know trying to
imagine yourself as like a 45 year old
who's still a tiny meat gang or more
dates I don't know hey Cody's already
there so yeah he's doing just fine but
then I think about guys like PewDiePie
they don't give a [ __ ] yeah and that
sounds objectively relatively silly to
me yeah and there's other other names
that are kind of you know out there I
think this is going to be totally normal
in 10 years like we're all gonna have
like weird pseudonyms that we yeah it's
like people with their gamer tags or
whatever yeah exactly like what's what's
like moist critical for example like
yeah no one really says anything about
it to me it's just that's his his uh I
mean Charlie and the thing with Charlie
is I feel like it's it's not even super
consistent like some people know him as
like penguin zero and other people know
him as moist critical yeah like that
part's kind of interesting too so yeah I
don't think you have to change it but I
feel you on getting a little bit older
and you know where it started do you
guys feel that at all are you just
saying it no no we feel better no no we
genuinely like okay uh anytime like
we're
I don't know people will refer to it as
Tiny meat gang and we will actively go
can we just go TMG I mean I think that
first like it got it got really
noticeable I guess when a we signed the
record deal and B we were like touring a
lot because then we started just being
in the room a lot with industry people
yeah and so we're like in the room at
this record label is like really
established you know Classic record
label and they're like tiny meat gang
welcome and it's like welcome tiny meat
gang on the wall they're just saying it
over and over and we're like God and all
these you know I've people that work
there that don't know us are like hey
who the [ __ ] are these guys coming yeah
you know yeah which is like fine because
we're comedy guys so and I guess there's
like a slight barrier to entry already
when you're getting into the comedy
space if you're kind of a YouTuber
probably I imagine and then dealing with
the extra layer of and they have this
you know sillyness around the yeah I can
imagine I mean even even when I go
perform at clubs I think the staff like
they kind of like read the background
and they'll read like tiny me and you I
can just tell when I get in there
they're like
okay this [ __ ] guy and then it's
typically by the end of the weekend
they're like oh okay like you actually
you actually care about stand up but
yeah there's like that initial yeah you
feel like you have to overcome it a
little bit and do extra good a little
bit win them over sort of thing
definitely yeah yeah but yeah no we've
definitely now we just try to say TMG
and even even like the audience like
it's like a fun bit now like I think
like during like the last shows of our
tour we were like okay when we all
understand that we're gonna have to like
all lie together like we're all gonna
have to pretend at one day TMG means
like the media guys or something yeah
yeah us and the audience so yeah so
would you say your Niche is
self-improvement still because I mean
it's not really even a niche anymore
it's like the Channel's [ __ ] huge
yeah and you talk about [ __ ] that like
is super interesting but it all kind of
falls in the same vein of like drugs
cosmetic surgery uh and then like
working out yeah I wouldn't say it's all
like some of the stuff that pops off is
related to those things but it's you
know if I'm if I want to make a topic
about business I'll talk about that yeah
oftentimes we do talk about pharmacology
and uh you know blood work and
optimization things of that nature but
um it's more so just what I'm interested
in and sometimes it'll vary sometimes
it's popular requests and it kind of
just depends yeah is that cool like is
it a little surreal that
you can make a living that way
yeah I just feel like for someone like
you and someone like us too it's like we
just start making these videos not
thinking anything's gonna happen yeah
and then a couple years later you're
like holy [ __ ] I'm on Joe Rogan all of a
sudden not that we've been there but you
know oh you're you're [ __ ] there like
objectively just you know yeah we're
the same height
yeah yeah
man like I'm sure you share a similar
sentiment to me on uh it's when you try
and in the moment it's really hard to
actually ground yourself and appreciate
it for what it is yeah when you zoom out
and look at it it's very much holy [ __ ]
yeah yeah wild yeah yeah but it's really
hard to actually Center yourself and be
able to evaluate it in that way because
you have this new Baseline
I don't know what you're used to and
your brain very much gets acclimated to
this kind of like Baseline of what
you're used to as far as you know video
performance or subscriber account or
whatever it's really hard to just look
at [ __ ] and be like wow millions of
people follow or hundreds of thousands
of people watch this thing yeah whatever
yeah yeah the you get desensitized to
the performance so quickly and then I
feel when you hit those strides on
YouTube where the performance is really
good and you're like okay this is normal
and then when you dip back down it feels
like oh my God yeah everything's [ __ ]
cratering like I can imagine for you
guys it's probably like I can't even I
can sort of Imagine but not quite the
desensitization to if you get under like
a million views on uh on a reaction
video or something yeah I'm sure for you
guys you're probably like [ __ ] yeah I I
personally used to get that way now I'm
just like it's whatever I think you know
I think things are so different now
people consume media in so many
different places
it's not how it was
four or five years ago but yeah I mean
that it's that's definitely still a real
thing like that we still care about the
performance you know no matter what it's
I think that's inevitable but I think
that's why people are drawn to you and
like your channel is that like you know
you're still filming on the same
background yeah dude like even though
you're getting all this attention
especially with the liver King thing
like you're breaking these huge ass
stories it kind of just still feels like
you're dedicated to the same things that
you were in the beginning just like yeah
trying to be as as informative as you
can trying to be as like I don't know
it's just it's something really
appealing about that you know I've
debated doing the whole upgrading as
much as I can getting higher production
value and then sometimes when I zoom out
and I'm like uh you know do I lose my
relatability a little bit or I don't
know stuff to say and predict yeah I I
that's why we've just kind of kept it
low-key yeah we just have to kind of
it's got this shitty spaceship thing
yeah yeah it's a homey sort of spaceship
yeah Vibes keep it regular yeah you know
no dude I think I think if you upgraded
I I think yours your point of motivation
is so concrete that I honestly think you
could do what you do in in any space I
think it's largely probably going to be
the same because you're still coming
from a place of you know because you've
experienced high performance you've
experienced great success and it's not
affecting your approach like you're
still pretty dedicated to like okay what
do I care about and like how can I
genuinely like tackle a topic and so I
think yeah you know whenever you feel
like it's right I would say do it
because the one thing I will say is when
you upgrade it does give you it kind of
like enhances your creativity a little
bit where you're like oh maybe you've
had this bigger space I could do
segments like this and then I could you
know
um you know whatever it can evolve
it can just enable you to do what you
like to do in a bigger way and sometimes
that is great so